[Music]
and Claire coffee news
I love Kolkata coughing coughing or
coughing coughing often as in life die
you go into the pollen yep when you
[ __ ] hit your wife in utility put in
a company submitted by Josie loves you
all Thank You Josie
a man hit his wife's body in a freezer
for eight he why because he loved her so
much he did not want to let her go or he
was a cannibal no it's because he loved
her so much he didn't want to let her go
although he wanted her to be like Jackie
the Titanic when he was frozen to that
board he was so hungry and he didn't
have money for food he decided to kill
her and eat her
how did I not find it if she went to me
see okay so Allen the husband Margaret
the wife Margaret I may live in Florida
by the way or radiation of them Margaret
died Murata in their condo back in 2002
and he never reported her death how did
she die she just old
yeah I'm assuming she just died in the
condo they don't really say how whenever
like the neighbors were asked like where
is she or anything he would respond that
she was in the nursing home what the
[ __ ] so Allen shot himself in 2010 eight
years later so with that entire time of
eight years he was collecting all of the
government money that was supposed to be
going to Margaret so they didn't find
out that he was keeping Margaret in the
freezer in the condo until after his
death when they were looking in silicon
oh so he shot himself
yes at the age of 86 he's like man I had
all this laundry piling up and I don't
know what it
Ellen he ended up taking was throughout
those eight years he took ninety two
thousand eighty eight dollars from
Social Security checks that were meant
to be for Margaret and then so once he
passed his heirs which I don't know who
they are accidental mention like if
they're kids or anything but his heirs
the only thing they could inherit was
the condo
since he owed or he took all that money
from the government to pay it back well
the government said that they were going
to take the condo and then whatever
money is left out of the sale would go
straight to the government so the air is
been in here
can you inherit that oh that's a good
one maybe this is a good question that I
actually wondered who would be more okay
depending on who died first do you think
you'd be more okay okay so would be more
pain I am a mess peanut it would be more
okay with who dying yeah I think KP is
fine if I know that's what he says in
its face but not in his heart I
guarantee it Oh what do you think you'll
be okay he loves he's like Men's
Wearhouse I mean yeah of course he loved
me but I feel like he can get over it
faster than I ever could you think you
just you just [ __ ] you've stuck on
that Chinese big and you can't get
another one that's like the opposite
girls are more like yeah I don't think I
can do it and then they actually survive
longer and guys are like that [ __ ] I
don't need her anyway but guys just die
right away
I always tell him like I have to die
first thank you you can you just be so
[ __ ] devastated I think yeah I think
I would probably die of a broken heart
down there I couldn't handle you know
why guys died like before it's not
because they missed the wife or anything
like that this is the real reason why so
I I see I see the way like old couples
are like my uncle not and all that stuff
the guy is on autopilot yeah so he
doesn't know how to [ __ ] take care of
himself he's like a child right she
remembers what time he should take his
medicine everything right and he can't
[ __ ] kick like do anything right so
he ends up [ __ ] he's probably going
to just kill himself because you just
like oh [ __ ] man I didn't take my pills
oh you know like stop something like
that's going to happen I think I think
that's why guys died before the girls
yeah the guys is too stressed out from
this regular daily life yesterday not
yesterday but a couple of weeks ago I
had to wash one sweater and I went into
the laundry room where I bought the
[ __ ] washer and dry so I know
the functions on these [ __ ] I
shopped and then I looked at it and I
was like how the [ __ ] do you use this I
was like blah
brother wash this sweater and then I was
pressing buttons I want Eva but ins
because I would just see a word this is
like Bishop machine wash and I'm like
and the better which is subscribing the
typos [ __ ] in washing machine it was
kind of the button damn it
notices people doesn't take care of
himself fully like he knows that I cook
you knows how to do laundry another
clean I think you're [ __ ] replaceable
as hell okay [ __ ] it sucks and I'm
irreplaceable dude that's crazy if I go
Mariel suck it devastated is she [ __ ]
not the killer stuff
okay I could do it I could do it I don't
think I don't think doc Gramm's in a you
[ __ ] he just went swimming and you
thought you were to die so I think I
don't think it's going to happen to well
even you could move on pretty quick not
pretty quick by there to move on how
will we see you're transmitting like to
your Spears that I wouldn't know a den
depends on how much you've built the
kids and all that stuff what the [ __ ]
we've already built a [ __ ] I'm done so
alright now you're thinking right now
alright now I know yeah [ __ ] right
now but you just would yeah [ __ ]
whatever probably be a tied in a
character once you go to look at your
shot the food I don't know I probably
saw for at least a year at least two
weeks
BAM L good that it was white left that I
operated yeah you wanna ask AC before
I'm like okay if let's say I die for
whatever reason how long do you think it
will take for you to get over me and
then you can like start looking into
dating someone else he was like I think
for sure like at least three months
no one whatever his mind you what that
was a compliment
yeah and I most girl there's one month
before you yeah three you know what our
girls got to kind of not take it
personal because I know where you're
coming from you're coming from this love
angle a lot of guys they could be with
you right now and they can still be
[ __ ] because it's a physical thing and
it has nothing to do with you okay go
and [ __ ] is my evil if you want to fudge
so what they say is that three months
could be hella long that could he could
be granting you the highest of highest
honors yeah oh my god he's giving you
the [ __ ] Hong Kong scepter of [ __ ]
six-month of a long time if I be if I
married many is a long time and I had a
kid with her I almost 100% guarantee I
would remarry you have a [ __ ] vagina I
swear right now right now if I married
if we had a kid I would have remarried I
swear you have a bigger remarry why
would I want to go through the same
[ __ ] arguments and [ __ ] again I
want more kids all pregnant women but if
I can't I can't look at my kid and then
be with somebody else because that kid
is with Mary you know so that's a
reminder of her my wife every [ __ ]
day and I look unless it's like the
Isaac syndrome where there's no [ __ ]
know that different oh you have that you
had an emotional separation from that
human being you know I mean the way the
kids look like oh you're lucky right my
clone you look absolutely you're so
melty like that something so if your
kids like and nothing like Mario not it
would just be weird man like I can't do
it just Albanese sad it was she was cut
from my life because of a [ __ ] of a
misfortunate event it wasn't because I
said I don't want you in my life anymore
it was I still want you but you got
taken so if she divorced you then you
could move on yeah of course
[ __ ] that [ __ ] at that point like what
the hell divorce is different report is
like she's saying to me hey it didn't
work out go [ __ ] yourself I'm like cool
go [ __ ] yourself - [ __ ] is my kid
that's different that's different but if
you guys are you like what are you going
to have for dinner honey I don't know
come home and then ya know I just want a
car accident yes that was not under
anyone's control cuz you know what if
she if she blew her brains out then it
makes you feel like oh she wasn't happy
with me oh yeah it changes the game
it changes the game well how do you feel
is like Mary Elizabeth thanks Susan that
I still wouldn't be able to be with
anybody it changes the game that's like
for me I'm loyal and gosh you guys know
me on the loyal ass [ __ ] I'm
right there with you David I don't want
to be with anybody else not because I
can't fall in love with anybody else
it's because I don't want the same
[ __ ] arguments and problems I don't
want the headache anymore on that on
that tip though I might be able to have
sex with me I don't think I'll be able
to be with somebody else now
that's that's what I'm saying like [ __ ]
it maybe cuz you want [ __ ] just don't be
with him good where are you but like if
it was the situation Joe arose where she
took her own life
I probably crying I'll talk to me and
then probably like bagels or something
not even like it's rebound sex you know
what guys do don't be crying while they
have sex I don't think what girls don't
understand is guys there's a sex drive
that is completely separate from their
heart feelers from their mind feelers
like guys are down a [ __ ] of [ __ ]
silicone things stuffed into a plastic
cup a [ __ ] flashlight
that's how [ __ ] stupid guys are if
this beam was soft on the inside guys
would [ __ ] this [ __ ] right so I think
guys next time is completely different
so I think like wow while I'm in
mourning I would still be horny
she'll be hope you [ __ ] a hooker with
tears coming out of his eyes
more like err I am going to commemorate
the spring of this come for my late wife
[ __ ] you what's my word for you I don't
get it I thought it was something
honorable no [ __ ] that
oh [ __ ] I'm so interested I don't
understand I don't understand at all
don't commemorate my death with the
hooker for you just [ __ ] do it by
yourself we're celebrating together at
the memorial
hope you guys enjoyed that video but if
you didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discuss just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video
up high
[Music]